[Music]
starting off this hour's josh in dallas
texas hey josh how are you
good how are you doing dave better than
we deserve brother how can we help
yes
i'm a federal employee and i heard you
talking to another controller not too
long ago about tsp and i was wondering
if you could be given too much in the
tsp that could
reduce your income
at the same time
i don't know if that was possible
if you could put too much into the tsp
yeah if your income
correct are you talking about taxable
income so you would use it
yeah aren't they offering a roth tsp now
yes we do have our tsp i'm on a
traditional tsp as well yeah i'm trying
to do a budget i did fpu
about seven years ago with my wife
but we kind of gotten out of control
lately and
i'm sitting there trying to figure out
where's all my money going i don't know
if it's gas and inflation mortgage so
i'm just trying to get it controlled my
money and budgeting but i don't know if
you could go to us uh too much in the
tsp
well or even taxes yeah
we recommend a roth more than a
traditional
and a match more than a roth and uh some
tsp has match most does not
and uh so i would i would i wouldn't
move the stuff that's in traditional
over but i would from this point forward
make my contributions into the wrath
and um uh
but all of that would be after you're
out of debt and have an emergency fund
yeah
would you yeah that's where i'm at i'm
kind of in debt um
but i was wondering if i could if i
should stop doing tsp you're in debt
yeah what kind of debt have you got
credit card and then used car payment
what's the total amount of the debt
let's see five on the credit card
and about
20 on the car
used car
okay well
how long would it take to pay off all
this debt right now if you got intense
about it
maybe
three months
okay what's your household income well i
actually have to say on the credit card
about three months and then the car
maybe another year ah
what's your household income
before taxes in 94.
so about 5 000 a month
um wife is a stay at home mom
okay
so all right well josh we we have
figured out that the shortest
path
the quickest path the most sure path to
wealth is to
get control of your largest wealth
building tool which is your income
meaning to get debt paid off before we
start investing
and so
we tell folks to work a plan called the
baby steps
and uh baby step one is you stop all
investing temporarily
and have a thousand dollars in the bank
how much do you have in savings is not
retirement
uh
savings we do have an emergency fund how
am i
900 and i'm getting close to doing a
thousand on an emergency fund so you've
kind of heard about this then yes yes we
did fbu a while back and now we're
trying to get back into it but we gave
away our books and everything okay well
we're going to put you back through it
because we want you to get we want you
didn't pass the first time
right
right
so
so
you know
we're going to do the baby steps which
means we're going to temporarily stop
retirement we're going to tighten this
budget down we're not doing anything
until we get this 25 000 paid off and i
think you can do it probably a little
faster than you're thinking
uh you probably are you know and should
be able to do it in a year
okay from today 100 done and then when
you're out of debt everything but the
house that's going gonna feel pretty
good then we're gonna take a thousand
dollar account build it up to three to
six months of expenses
then we'll start the tsp back up in the
roth
okay
josh i know it hurts to pause that
investing you're excited about building
wealth but the truth is
when you pause investing it's going to
accelerate the debt payoff and when you
accelerate the debt payoff you can then
accelerate the investing because a lot
of people are scraping by trying to
throw you know percentages at the
investment but the truth is instead of
putting five percent in and you're
hoping to get to 10 you're gonna be able
to put 15 when you don't owe anyone
anything and so that's what we want for
you and that's what i did and man it's a
game changer